internet nos abre la puerta a muchas
cosas en la vida a mí me llevo a la
posibilidad de estar aquí frente a
ustedes compartiendo les esta charla
principalmente en primera instancia
porque me dio la posibilidad de conocer
qué son las charlas de vex y decirme
algún día quiero estar ahí
internet nos da la posibilidad de
conocer gente y lugares de todo el mundo
aprender a distancia aprender a cocinar
a manejar y por qué no a enamorarnos
todo esto ha llevado a internar a
convertirse en lo que yo llamo el país
de las maravillas'
cuántos de nosotros en algún momento
hemos tenido la posibilidad de recibir
algún mensaje de notificación de alguien
que no conocemos pero al momento de
responder lo hacemos como si lo
conociéramos de toda la vida
hace un tiempo recuerdo haber recibido
una un mensaje de una chica que me
solicitaba apoyo para la realización
de un proyecto escolar sin embargo
después de muchas horas de prácticas
nocturnas y pláticas de contenido que no
tenía nada relación respecto al proyecto
en sí y principalmente que ella vivía en
otro estado de la república
terminó por generar en mí hasta cierto
punto una especie de enamoramiento
terminó por convertirse en micros o en
el amor platónico para los que estamos
un poquito más grandes de edad
si de cuenta había compartido
información
información que probablemente para ti o
para mí no significa absolutamente nada
sin embargo esa información en las manos
equivocadas
o en las manos correctas puede
significar que nuestra identidad digital
pueda verse gravemente comprometida pero
principalmente puede hacer que nos pueda
afectar a nuestra vida real
cuántos de nosotros el momento de hacer
uso del internet normalmente solemos
decir no pasa nada
no pasa nada si comparte esta fotografía
o vídeo
pero cuántos de nosotros nos hacemos la
pregunta de qué podría pasar si
qué podría pasar si comparto de ese
contenido lo que podría pasar si
realmente la otra persona no es quien
dice ser o qué podría pasar si no
fuéramos ni tú ni yo los que estamos
compartiendo ese contenido si fuera el
más pequeño de tu casa o el más pequeño
de tus hijos
ella es lisa elisa tiene una mejor amiga
de 12 años llamada m
ellas hablan todo el tiempo a través de
internet se comparten sus hobbies sus
gustos musicales y todas sus series y
películas de ciencia ficción que tanto
les gusta sin embargo las últimas
semanas elisa ha estado un poco distante
como ausente un poco estresada inclusive
se le nota ha tenido muchos cambios de
humor sus padres lo atribuyen al posible
la adolescencia sin embargo el momento
de preguntarle lo único que hace mención
es que ha tenido una discusión con su
amiga pero no les cuenta más
hace unos meses realizamos una serie de
campañas contra la difusión de contenido
no consentido o mejor conocido como
difundir el pack
a raíz de ello hubo muchas personas que
no solicitaron ayuda algunas no
solicitaron ayuda principalmente porque
su contenido ya se había sido difundido
a través de internet y nos pedían ayuda
para tratar de eliminar ese contenido
sin embargo de entre todas las personas
resaltó una una niña pequeña de 10 años
que al momento de preguntarle qué era lo
que le sucedía y cómo podíamos ayudarle
nos hizo mención que la estaban
amenazando la estaban amenazando con
compartir una serie de fotografías y
vídeos donde ella salía en ropa interior
con compartirse la a sus padres ya todos
sus amigos de la escuela
le preguntamos
que era específicamente lo que estaba
sucediendo y nos hizo mención que su
amiga oa raíz de una conversación donde
se había molestado a su amiga había
surgido esa amenaza
le preguntamos por qué lo había hecho y
principalmente porque era que su amiga
tenía fotografías y videos de ella en
ropa interior
al momento de preguntarle esto nos
contestó qué pasa es que me gusta un
niño en la escuela
y emma al ser mayoría tener novio me
dijo que me podía ayudar pero únicamente
me diría si seguía sus consejos al pie
de la letra
me dio consejos sobre cómo maquillarme
sobre cómo vestirme
inclusive sobre cómo posar para aparecer
más atractivo para esa persona
todo esto lo hacíamos a través de
videollamadas a través de fotografías
para que ella diera o no su aprobación
le hicimos mención a la persona que
acompañaba la pequeña que era necesario
hablar con los padres para denunciar a
esta persona
en ese momento escuchamos un grito decir
no
porque mis padres me van a regañar y me
van a pegar
no podemos hacerlo sin ellos
después de un silencio
unos meses y después de una
investigación
descubrimos que emma realmente tiene 45
años
y que no se llama demás sino juan
y se dedica a la comercialización de
contenido de pornografía infantil a
través de internet
esta persona es la que amenazaba a la
pequeña y lisa con compartir ese
contenido y principalmente para evitar
que ese contenido fuera difundido con
sus padres y sus amiguitos
amenazaba a la pequeña con la única
condición de que le pudiera entregar más
contenido ahora donde la pequeña salía
desnuda
y principalmente que le entregara el
contenido personalmente por desgracia
esas fotografías y vídeos es probable
que terminen en sitios de pederastía de
pornografía infantil y no pueda
eliminarse ese contenido
el problema aquí es porque hay más
confianza
y no se le menciona un extraño de que
algo sucede antes que nuestra propia
familia
y la pregunta aquí es si algo así llega
a suceder en tu casa el más pequeño de
tu familia tendría la confianza
necesaria para poder hacerte mención que
algo está sucediendo según el consejo
europeo existen seis acciones que
alguien puede emprender contra nosotros
a través de internet
crímenes de odio cuántos de nosotros
hemos tenido la posibilidad de escuchar
o de ver que alguien ejerce
discriminación contra grupos vulnerables
a través de internet ciberacoso cuántos
de nosotros hemos recibido o conocido a
alguien que ha recibido insultos o
amenazas a través de los diferentes
tipos de redes sociales
delitos digitales cuántos de nosotros
hemos tenido la posibilidad ya sea de
escuchar o inclusive nosotros mismos
a vernos que nos hayan hackeado nuestras
redes sociales o que se hayan visto
comprometida a nuestras cuentas de banco
delitos contra la privacidad cuántos de
nosotros hemos sufrido o conocido a
alguien al cual se le ha suplantado su
identidad o su contenido íntimo se ha
visto filtrado a través de internet como
le sucede a la pequeña elisa
amenazas físicas cuántos hemos tenido la
posibilidad e inclusive de haber sufrido
alguna amenaza respecto a algo que
publicamos en redes sociales
y principalmente
y el más triste de todos el abuso y la
explotación sexual de menores a través
de internet
cuántos de nosotros hemos tenido la
posibilidad de ver de escuchar o de
conocer
a algún sitio página o grupo inclusive
un chat donde se comparten contenidos de
pornografía infantil como si fuera el
contenido más inocente del mundo
y todo lo que les menciono todo sucede
aquí nada sucede en la dark ni en la
deep web ni en películas ni en series
todo sucede en la vida real y todo
sucede a un dispositivo de distancia
porque así su internet
en algún momento puede significar ser el
país de las maravillas' y en otro
momento
a causa de un error puede convertirse en
el lugar más oscuro y profundo del cual
nos va a costar mucho trabajo salir
existen diferentes problemáticas
respecto a estos puntos
uno de ellos es la falta de educación la
falta de educación respecto al riesgo
así de salamina y las amenazas
tecnológicas al momento de hacer uso de
internet y los dispositivos móviles y
asimismo en la orfandad digital
y el otro punto respecto a los pequeños
principalmente es la orfandad digital la
orfandad digital hace referencia a los
jóvenes y adolescentes que han crecido
con el uso de las tecnologías sin
embargo sus padres han tenido poca uno
en las conversaciones
respecto a los riesgos y las amenazas
que implica el uso de las mismas sin
embargo que lo que podemos hacer como
consultor en ciberseguridad te quiero
compartir una frase que me ayuda mucho
en la realización de mi trabajo
prevención antes que reacción
y cómo podemos prevenir
uno de ellos es escuchando
cuántos de nosotros en algún momento nos
han dicho por eso jamás te cuento nada
eres muy exagerado el escuchar nos
permitirá simplemente mantener un nivel
de comunicación correcto con el menor
nos va a abrir su confianza y esto va a
hacer que en algún momento si algo puede
llegar a sucederle esta persona pueda y
tenga la posibilidad de compartir nos
que lo que le sucede estar atentos estar
atentos a cambios de humor cambios de
ánimo inclusive a cambios en el uso de
los dispositivos
si una persona utiliza mucho un
dispositivo y de un momento a otro
quiere dejarlo prácticamente eso
significa o puede ser señal de que algo
puede estar mal
pero principalmente es importante educar
educar y conocer nada de esto es un tema
de expertos en tecnología todos debemos
de conocer temas de seguridad debemos de
conocer los riesgos y las amenazas
adicional a ello debemos de conocer y
educar respecto a la parte de sexualidad
esto con la finalidad de que ellos
mismos puedan conocer cuáles son las
consecuencias y los riesgos de prácticas
como el sexting y así mismo tengan la
posibilidad de identificar en etapas
tempranas
actividades contra ellos como el
grooming también es importante educar
respecto al uso seguro del uso de las
tecnologías y las consecuencias de
compartir contenido en internet de forma
indiscriminada
nada de esto se trata de estar
paranoicos sino de estar alerta
nada de esto se trata de prohibir
o de instalar mucha tecnología con la
finalidad de prohibir y tratar de
bloquear todo el contenido que no esté
permitido por controles parentales
te cuento un secreto la mayoría de las
redes de pederastia y de pornografía
infantil se mueven en aplicaciones y en
redes sociales que están permitidas por
los controles parentales
el problema no son las aplicaciones el
problema es el uso que se les da y la
falta de conocimiento que existen través
de ahí por eso yo te invito te invito a
que puedas educarte respecto a los temas
a los riesgos y a las amenazas que
existen a través del uso de las redes
sociales y de internet esto nos dará las
herramientas para estar preparados
y principalmente de evitar caer en algún
problema como en el que le sucedió a
ellis
porque internet no es un mundo aparte es
una extensión de nuestra realidad
[Aplausos]